five time Pro Bowler and spectacular Cal
bear for the New Orleans Saints back
here on the Rich Eisen show how are you
sir
I'm good add me on the shelves you got
it
what do you think of the three seed
Cameron when it's all said and done hey
hey give it the chance to make a run at
the championship
it's exactly what we want so when you
talk about what we have in our minds
what we have you know our focus on
locker room I mean you know clearly we
wanted a Buy and have the ability to
have home-field advantage but at the end
day we know that we have an offensive
man roster we have the we have the
ability to shuffle together a stretch of
wins together and you know come out at
thirteen and three so we know we can
play anywhere and beat anybody no I know
the it is the Midway you can can't you
can only control what you can control
type of mentality here but were you
watching Sunday Night Football rooting
for Russell Wilson were you doing that I
don't know about rooting for Russell
Wilson but I was you know I was looking
for the demise of the Niners you can't
even bring yourself to say that you were
hoping for Seattle to win you can't even
you can't even say the words Cameron I
love it I was rooting for Marshawn Lynch
go bears oh there you go how about that
too right I mean he looked like he had a
quick first step on occasion right no
doubt no doubt
fresh legs and I mean you know he came
in focus
yeah I love it we had him on the one and
that's that's a stellar touchdown he
jumped over the pile and then it was
great hey moving back to you know fourth
quarter couple seconds left or couple
minutes left whatever was up second you
know you're on the one again I might
just give it to my son and then they get
delay of game you're just sitting there
like come on do that wherever I found
you Cameron wherever Colt were you
calling from paint the picture for me
here oh it's off day yeah but uh you
know with the through the kids the game
from Sunday oh no we're in training 100
ACT rehab right now okay so you're in
the training room but the else is around
there can you tell me where that's
that's tellin telling too many tales out
of school
yep and I was in the training room yeah
everybody that needs to be here is here
okay very good
what what challenges do these Vikings
presents to you sir you know you know
the running game you know you know
they're their children and really open
up the passing lanes through the ground
attack we just got done watching film on
you know the Seattle game the Green Bay
game and there's bear and you know this
last game this Bears game and you look
at it and you know you know they're
running game you know who they have my
receiver you already you're already
aware of what Cousins is capable of
doing once he gets his good confidence
built up early I think they do a great
job of doing that
mm-hmm and the the issue of knowing what
type of Dalvin cook you're gonna get
what do you think I meant run the issue
of knowing what Kirk Cousins you're
going to get what do you mean by that
Cameron to be a very proficient yes Oh
quarterback mm-hmm and and at other
times maybe not so much is all you're
saying man you are you are one of a kind
sir so the defensive line of there's
been obviously a lot of injuries on that
front for you and you mentioned the the
training room what is the current status
for you and your your line mates going
into this weekend best you can reveal
and tell me here yeah you know the last
couple games you've seen what I do mine
has been able to do instead been a
absent pass rusher
get after quarterback you know Terry
Henderson has seamlessly transitioned
into a starter and I think he's been
rushing really well probably got more
pressure than you know sacks and he's
still irritated about but at the end day
he loved to speed the way he's dressing
up that there's not really a drop-off he
talked about with Morrow every
sending capable of doing in terms of
rotating in and playing is its entire
season you just been growing and
maturing so you're seeing the
culmination of these two players really
fill in that often in row well you you
also lost rankings and Davenport in that
49ers game that left the 49ers also for
the next week when they were playing
Atlanta without seven defensive starters
what in the world was going on in that
game in terms of the physical nature
where does that rank for you in that
game Cameron yeah I mean it's up there
you talk about the totally took on both
teams at the end a you know that was
games ago I almost can't even say like
exactly what happened we do know the you
know the next game we went down a DB you
then the next game we were down another
DB and yet you know we're still finding
ways to win so you know what it is it's
the NFL season the 16 games you have to
have that next man up mentality well I
mean Cameron Jordan here for the New
Orleans Saints on the Rich Eisen show no
nobody and no team really can can state
that with such confidence like the
Saints and and you with Teddy
Bridgewater I mean the fact that you
have 13 wins going into this weekend
five of them were when Brees went down
I'm wondering if what you could state
about the importance of what Teddy did
for your team as you move forward here
yeah I mean he sort of got certain to
the mix is that Rams game early on but
then of course that next week you know
you bounce back in Seattle we we go to
Seattle mediary from LA to Seattle we
bond as a team you bring it that
closeness that Cooke tight-knit feel of
a brotherhood and you know put our backs
against the wall and just realize you
know we're all we got and nobody really
cares about you know if one of our best
players goes down one of our leaders
goes down it's all about you know the
wind that the other day saying that
Teddy came in you know formed formed
into his game plan and literally took
over at helm and made we made a heck of
a run then drew comes back of course and
accepting as it is you see that 13 and 3
so what Teddy did was would be an
alternate pro know exactly we have it's
not like you know we had somebody who
wasn't reliable this is you know teddy
bridgewater somebody who had been a pro
bowl caliber quarterback and then
obviously yeah you see what he does and
then you've got your goat did you notice
the NFL 100 all-time quarterbacks list
there in New Orleans Cameron I think I
think brought to my attention like two
days of the game feels like Aaron
Rodgers left off and Drew Brees left off
hey just sit there he's like alright
well you know you know they have to put
a couple of these older quarterbacks up
there but I I don't I don't grasp the
concept of how you leave off on the
greatest quarterbacks of all time on a
captain I mean it's just it goes without
saying that a guy drew Brees and all the
records that heals all the registers
that he's broken is not clearly a top
three quarterback of all time why mine
it goes it goes drew Peyton Tom drew Tom
Hayden drew yeah it doesn't really
matter that the top three order but
that's just is what it is yeah and I'm
wonder do you watch the offense
sometimes you just sometimes just yeah
absolutely
what's more exciting than you know after
you have a button you know a quick three
and out whether or a forced fumble you
see your office go to work and put into
a quick try to put points up the board I
mean nothing's more fun than watching
you know jewry's take the field and be
able to sling the rocks and mike thomas
miller you know swing it to see Jared
could be able to hand it off to you know
a K or the takers and watch how
productive they office those these in
terms of what are off the line is being
capable doing to other teams
systematically shutting down top tier
passages from JJ Watt to Shaq Barrett -
you know Chandler Jones whoever it is
and not only that but push the the
running back presence it's overly
exciting to watch you know I had Mike
Thomas on a couple weeks ago Cameron and
you know in the same way that you you
couldn't bring yourself to you know talk
well of an opponent in a way or admit
anything you know for me is that went
Michigan Wolverine it's not easy but I
place to decide because I'm a lead-pipe
wielding professional I love the kid I
love his attitude I love everything
about him the way he goes about his
business the way he wants to be better
and how amazing he is and how his
Twitter handle is can't guard Mike and
and you can't you know I'm wondering
what it's like watching him work as a
teammate for you I mean I said all the
time you know Kent gar Mike you come in
as a rookie and your Twitter handle
can't gar Mike you know something he's
gonna get roasted on my phone oh but you
came in and they won and lived up to
expectations so I mean we we've watched
his work ethic he watched his demeanor
and how he feels like he's always had a
chip on his shoulder you know you can
draft in the second round at Ohio State
I guess that's a chip but um yeah the
way that he he attacks practice is the
way you see him run his routes in a game
I mean he's got that same intensity he's
got that same demeanor every route that
he runs last one for you Cameron you
know obviously I know it's a sore
subject but you're you know it's coming
I'm sure it's already been asked of you
or if it hasn't mom might be the first
it's it's obviously the manner in which
the Saints lost the last playoff game
with the Vikings is that at all in your
mind's about trying to erase it with a W
in front of your home fans and bounce
this team and take care of business
emphatically I don't I mean I know the
last time we played the Vikings we want
I know this last time you know we lost
in a playoff against the Vikings I was
with like three quarterbacks ago or four
quarterbacks ago at this point we didn't
that was a season where they played
three or four different quarterbacks and
has the chest of them all or three or
four different running backs in high
success they're all elsewhere or you
know what I think maybe might bring
injured at the time um that was an
entirely different team you know allow
the team that was primarily boosted by
Adam Thielen and they're decent he
didn't know too much about Stefan Dixit
now you know we're we're decent that's
grown from that we we feel that was
three years ago we had a DB core that
was all Ricky's almost here are all
Ricky's in a second year and so now we
come in and our defense has grown so
much whoever's in front of us it doesn't
matter now I'm unaffected by the last
time we played Minnesota that would be
actual question okay
Cameron you take care of yourself I
really appreciate the time calling in
from the training room best to you and
yours on a happy new year and I hope you
will be checking you out yeah I'm not
looking for this cold Club action but
whatever works for the playoffs there
you go you're in the playoffs thanks to
the call Cameron you take care you best
at cam Jordan 94 for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
under red TV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app